the jurogan experience like they're
telling people
not to scream at disneyland do you know
that
yeah yeah they told me when you go on
rides don't scream like okay
i'm gonna mime it i'm gonna wow that's
that's so they also tell you to keep
your arms and hands down and no one ever
[ __ ] no one ever does that
right yeah i hope people scream instead
of protest they're probably gonna stop
people from screaming though they're
probably gonna tell people
because you know look they don't want an
inspector to come there and say hey
people are screaming we're gonna shut
this place down
you know they've disneyland's been
closed for a [ __ ] year and they're
losing some insane amount it's like 300
million dollars a day or something crazy
yeah like it's nuts i might have made
that number
i pulled that right out of my house how
much money is disneyland losing per
day while disneyland's being closed i
think it might be 100 million i i really
do
i think isn't that what it costs for a
churro at disneyland
disneyland 100 million it's less than
that
yeah there's got to let's guess before
you
i say 100 million what do you say um
i'll say 50 million okay i like what
you're doing price is right
let's go i just have no idea a hundred
million seems
like if you guessed a million i would
have been like maybe
i would have probably guessed half of
that that just seems like so much money
it's way more than a million
disneyland is huge and it's really
[ __ ] expensive and then you got
disneyland and california
adventure on the same park i've barely i
can count on one hand the amount of
times i've had more than two thousand
dollars
at once in my life so i don't have a
concept of what a million dollars
is it's a lot of money but it's not a
lot of money if you you're running
disneyland
i mean that's probably their [ __ ]
rent what do you got jamie it's giving
me just disney's overall disney's a
gigantic company so
right it's not breaking it down just for
disneyland did you write disneyland is
losing
yes yes so now i'm looking per day how
much is disneyland's daily revenue
and then that's no no just say how much
is disneyland using per day
it's adding it all together with disney
the company and how much they lost in
china and orlando
and the tv channels and all that did you
write disneyland yes
[ __ ] i know there was an article
jamie you'll get it
i know you will i have faith there's
gotta be like a middle
ground you know where like let people do
whatever the [ __ ] they want like let
people do whatever the [ __ ] they want
and like put those little dots where
people can stand a little bit further
apart i think we should have been doing
that anyway
i've always thought handshaking was
disgusting i think we should all stop
shaking hands for the rest of our lives
when i was looking back at my old
material i found two
separate bits i tried to write about how
shaking hands
is nasty before covid
i didn't even realize i felt that
strongly about it except that
i did i was always like a fist bumper or
like
better yet don't touch me after shows
you don't have to [ __ ] touch me dude
i've had
men kiss me on my mouth after shows i've
had people like grab my stomach after
show i've
like people put their hands on me and
try to touch me and i'm like
we don't it's it's journalism how many
one took me a while to add that up
well i tried to fish i was like i mean
men have kissed me on my face
one guy kissed me on my mouth but i was
pushing
him off of me and yelling stop what the
[ __ ] are you doing
and like the people with them were like
laughing and i was like what the [ __ ] is
your problem this is not i
i snapped on him i yelled at him and
then i didn't shake anyone's hands after
that
that's the difference between being a
woman comic and being a male comic dudes
have never tried to kiss me
i've never had a guy i honestly don't
even believe you i feel like
dudes have tried to kiss you i feel like
you've probably been kissed on and off
by more with 30 or 40 years
uh a couple women are trying to kiss me
but it's not threatening
you know that's the difference that's
just because you're into it just because
you're
into it no it's not dangerous like they
can't really rape me
you know what i'm saying i feel
threatened on your behalf but i respect
your
right to feel safe thank you i'm glad
that you feel
safe feeling threatened on my behalf but
my point is like a woman is not
physically scary to me yeah where a man
is
physically scary to a woman here it goes
deep info
uh okay here it goes 12 million per day
well i'm way off yeah that's just for
disneyland
12 million per day based on 2 000
god i was like 300 million coronavirus
closures cost disneyland 7.9 million per
day and disneyland california adventure
4.1 million per day
yeah damn i didn't realize in orlando
so when you start adding it all up it
starts getting walt disney world in
florida lost
25 million per day it's way bigger
though oh
interesting magic kingdom 8.8 million
per day
animal kingdom 5.8 million per day epcot
5.2
and hollywood studios 4.8
okay i was way off i was going to go
with a billion a day how about that
so what is it 14 is that what it said 14
million today
that's still a shitload of money add
that over 365 days and you got a lot of
cheddar
says three 250 million a week yeah
yeah that's billions damn billions of
dollars
just because someone told them they have
to shut i mean they would have
definitely lost money
period there's no way to not lose some
money everybody lost
some money but to lose that much money
is just preposterous well then if you
think about those workers
think about how much they could possibly
be collecting in unemployment
and it's got to be a hundred bucks a
week i mean it's got to be so low if
they were minimum wage workers
because you just get a fraction of that
and where can you live
on a hundred bucks a week like where can
you pay rent what room can you
what closet can you rent i'm not talking
about having your own apartment i'm
saying like where can you live for that
amount of money
you can't you can't you have to live
with your parents you have to hope they
they can pay their mortgage it's
interesting like what we just did there
is basically what's happening in
california in terms of fear of
covid like when there's a person
that ramps it up so high like a hundred
million dollars a day
you came in at 50 million a day right
that was your estimate after i came in
with 100 million a day meanwhile
we're both way off mm-hmm like that's
in a sense like what in california
everyone's like we're all going to die
everyone's going to die and then if
you're reasonable you're like no only
like 30
of us are going to die and then you're
like wait a minute it's not even that
30 would be wild that's what like the
bubonic
plague killed well that was what a lot
of people were seriously worried about
really i've had people express to me
today that five percent of people that
get covered die i'm like
bro that's not possible that's not true
it's not true it's less than one percent
and then you also have the problem of
die from covid or die with covid because
most people who die have an average of
2.6
comorbidities and i think they've
recently elevated that
i think it's more than that now which
means they have either
diabetes or some some other cancer some
other disease that
makes makes them extremely vulnerable
then they get covered and then they die
of it
doesn't mean you should minimize the
fact that they died and coveted
definitely killed them because if it
wasn't for cover they would have
probably stayed alive
but they were not doing good already
catch new episodes of the joe rogan
experience for free
only on spotify watch back catalog jre
videos on spotify
including clips easily seamlessly switch
between
video and audio experience on spotify
you can listen to the jre
in the background by using other apps
and can download episodes to save on
data cost
all for free spotify is absolutely free
you don't have to have a premium account
to watch new jre episodes
you just need to search for the jre on
your spotify
app go to spotify now to get this full
episode of the joe rogan experience